The best part about
today I would say
is how smoothly everything
went with the sixth graders.
I was stressed about it.
They actually had pretty
constructive feedback,
so I'm happy about
how that went.
The worst part about today,
I feel like people feel lost.
They kind of had a deer in the
headlights look on their faces
sometimes, because
we're really talking
at a more abstract
conceptual level,
and they haven't had a chance
to put stuff into practice yet.
And I know that'll
change tonight,
and I know that the workshops
and stuff will help tomorrow
and the rest of this
week, but at some point,
I just felt like
I was saying words
that weren't super useful to
them, and I couldn't stop.
I should've just shut
up, but I didn't.
Reconfiguring our furniture
arrangement in this U shape
definitely made the
class feel more intimate,
and I think that
maybe that contributed
to them talking a lot more
compared to yesterday.
I mean, there are a lot
of compounding variables
with that, but they did
seem to talk a lot more.
If I could do anything
different today-- well,
maybe leaving more
time for scripting.
I really was going
to rely on tomorrow
to be the big scripting
day, and I realize now
that that probably wasn't the
greatest idea because people
don't know how to script.
And of course they
don't, because who
does if you haven't
ever done it before.
I'm excited about tomorrow
because it's a more calm day.
It's more relaxed.
It's more informal.
It's more normal.